im Studio begrüße ich nun Professor
Andreas heinemann-grüder er ist
Politikwissenschaftler und
russland-experte guten Tag Herr
Professor grüner
diese redere gestern die sie sich im
Original vor der Sendung wie sie mir
erzählt haben vorhin noch mal angehört
haben ist diese Rede nicht in Wahrheit
eine richtige Kriegserklärung an die EU
die USA und den gesamten Westen
es ist ein Aufruf eigentlich zu einem
totalen Krieg mit dem Westen auf der
einen Seite hat Putin noch mal alle
rhetorischen Figuren aus der
Vergangenheit Genozid an den russenheim
ins Reich tausendjährige Geschichte der
kiewerus und so weiter wiederholt auf
der anderen Seite war der Hauptteil der
Rede eigentlich wir führen keinen Krieg
mehr gegen die Ukraine sondern wir
führen einen Kampf um Sieg oder
Niederlage mit dem Westen wo die Ukraine
dann eben mit eingeschlossen ist weil
Putin sagte ja auch die Drahtzieher
würden im Westen sitzen jetzt befürchten
manche in der Ukraine offenbar auch eine
neue Qualität des Krieges die da
möglicherweise auf sie zukommt sie auch
ist das auch ihre Befürchtung teilen Sie
die
Putin hat er jetzt vier Gebiete
sozusagen zusätzlich annektiert also die
Krim ist schon annektiert aber jetzt
vier zusätzliche Gebiete die jetzt als
staatstherritorium Russlands angesehen
werden das heißt also wenn die Ukraine
mit Unterstützung des Westens hier diese
Gebiete angreift wird Putin das als
Angriff auf Russland ansehen und er sagt
wenn ihr Russland angreift dann werdet
ihr auch mit dem gesamten
eskalationspotential Russlands zu tun
haben die neue Qualität ist auch die
dass die Bürger die Männer in diesen
Gebieten automatisch russische
Staatsbürger sind das heißt gezwungen
werden auf der russischen Seite zu
kämpfen wer nicht für Russland kämpft
wird als Deserteur angesehen oder als
Extremist oder Terrorist das heißt
diejenigen die bisher noch Staatsbürger
der Ukraine Waren werden plötzlich als
Staatsbürger Russlands angesehen und
insofern Teil der Mobilisierung also
eine schlimme Situation für die
Betroffenen Ukrainer und vielleicht auch
für die Russen in diesen Regionen die
nicht für Putin kämpfen wollen
unterdessen während diese Propaganda
entfaltet wird ist die Situation auf dem
Schlachtfeld für die Russen sehr
schlecht die Ukrainer Rücken vor wir
hören in der Region Limani sind drei bis
fünf tausend russisches Soldaten
eingeschlossen wie passt denn das
zusammen also die
Russen sind natürlich überrascht gewesen
von der ukrainischen Offensive die auch
noch anhält da hat auch immer auch
Irreführungen erfolgreich auf Seiten der
Ukraine weil sie eigentlich mit einer
anderen Angriffs Taktik die Russen und
sozusagen
verwirrt haben das hat eine Rolle
gespielt aber man kann nicht davon
ausgehen dass diese ukrainische
Offensive der letzten zwei Monate so
weiterzuführen ist also der Krieg wird
schmutziger es wird auch gegen
offensiven der Russen geben und die
Russen werden alles reinwerfen in diesen
Krieg um dieses Blatt zu wenden das
heißt sie werden alles tun um die vier
annektierten Gebiete in der Tat
militärisch unter Kontrolle zu bringen
und dann sozusagen jetzt haben wir unser
Kriegsziel erreicht und das werden sie
mit allem Personal und allem Material
machen und insofern glaube ich die
Gegenwart der Phase wir sollten uns
nicht also einmal die ukrainische
Offensive als Ende des Krieges schön
reden vielen Dank bis sie hin wir wollen
gemeinsam mal schauen in das was
Präsident selenski in Kiew in der Nacht
gesagt hat es kam ja wie gesagt dieses
Angebot wir verhandeln in Moskau aber
nur ohne Protein zunächst ging aber
Präsident selensky in der täglichen
Ansprache auf den mutmaßlich russischen
Angriff auf eine Fahrzeugkolonne bei
saporicia ein dabei sind vorgestern 30
Menschen getötet worden alles Zivilisten
den heutigen Tag mit einer bewussten
voll berechnenden Ermordung der Ukraine
in sakorice raketenschlag gegen die
zivile Autokolonne Futter dazu dass 30
Tote sind fast 100 Verletzte die
russische Militärs wussten wohin sie
ihre Raketen schicken das haben die
Unmenschen gemacht vom ersten bis zum
letzten von dem der diesen Befehl
erteilte und bis zu dem der diesen
Befehl erfüllte sie werden unbedingt
dafür verantwortlich sein vom Gesetz und
von Menschen vor Menschen aus diesem
Grund sind wir sicher an unserem Sieg
aus diesem Grund haben wir die
Initiative im Krieg übernommen aus
diesem Grund spüren wir jetzt sichtbare
Ergebnisse auf dem Schlachtfeld und das
ist sehr wichtig ich gratuliere die
Helden denn wir bleiben Menschen und wir
bekommen die Unterstützung von Menschen
von allen Menschen der Welt von jedem
und von jedem der den Schmerz verspürt
Werner spür und erfährt über die
Ermordung der unschuldigen Menschen und
in Moskau fand heute irgendwelche
ehrlich gesagt nächste fast statt es
wurde etwas ausgezeichnet etwas kandiert
gesungen auf dem Platz es wurde über
saporisha gesprochen und in saporisha
haben Sie so etwas veranstaltet und
Menschen sind das Unmenschen ewiges
gedenken allen die gefallen sind infolge
der russischen Terrorakte Ukraine hat
heute eine Entscheidung getroffen zu
eigenen Verteidigung und diese
Entscheidungen werden das war der die
Entscheidung des Oberkommandos und des
Rates für Verteidigung der Ukraine ich
habe bereits erzählt über unseren Antrag
zum Beitritt der NATO zu einer
beschleunigsten Verfahren und ich habe
erklärt über die Bereitschaft der
Ukraine zu Verhandlungen mit der
Russischen Föderation aber bereits mit
einem anderen Präsidenten Russlands der
versteht was wirklich geschieht ich
möchte noch etwas erzähl über die
Entscheidung des Rates unseres
Verteidigung da dass es Sanktionen gegen
die russischen
Persönlichkeiten das sind ziemlich
bekannte Persönlichkeiten aber die
orientieren uns nicht auf die
Bekanntheit der Persönlichkeit wir
wollen russischen Einfluss stoppen und
auch die Entscheidungen in russischen
Föderation selbst einführen wir führen
die Einschränkungen für eine Reihe
einige tausende der Subjekte aus
Russland wir führen neue Sanktionen
gegen die schlüsselpersönlichkeiten
gegen die bedeutende russische
Unternehmen ein natürlich werden die
Sanktionen auch eingeführt gegenüber den
Bürger und andere Staaten die sich an
der russischen Fass Beteiligten in den
besetzten Gebieten unseres Landes sollte
Referenzen sind Elemente eine Aggression
gegen einen souveränen statt und jeder
der sich an der Partei an dieser Fass
beteiligt wird zur Verantwortung gezogen
werden ich habe heute mit den
Premierminister von Japan und Dänemark
gesprochen natürlich haben sie die
russischen eskalationsschritte
verurteilt ich danke Ihnen für die
Unterstützung ich bedanke mich bei
vielen Führern der Staaten bei Paten bei
allen Persönlichkeiten der Welt die ganz
operativ sich geäußert haben zum Schutz
der Ukraine und das Völkerrechts ich
möchte mich bedanken persönlich beim
Präsidenten der Vereinigten Staaten
beiden beim Kongress und bei unseren
Partner in Europa die bereits die
Sanktionen gegen die russischen
Unternehmen verstärken und alles Tun zu
Unterstützung und finanzielle
Unterstützung der Ukraine wir müssen
unser Land befreien und das wird der
beste Beweis dass das Völkerrecht und
die menschlichen Werte kein terrorstadt
brechen kann und selbst ein solche
unverschämter Stadt wie Russland wir
haben bedeutende Ergebnisse im Osten
unseres Landes darüber gibt es
ausreichend öffentliche Informationen
alle haben gehört was in Lehmann im
Gebiet Donezk stattfindet das sind
Schritte die für uns viel bedeuten
ja soweit der ukrainische Präsident
selenski in der Nacht mit seiner
Ansprache
Professor Heinemann grüner diese
Propaganda Show die wir da gestern
gesehen haben mit der Sprache die Putin
entfaltet die Geschichte hat uns auf das
Schlachtfeld gerufen um für unser Volk
zu kämpfen für das große historische
Russland für künftige Generation Zitat
Ende ist ja nur ein Beispiel für die
Rhetorik die er da angewandt hat man
muss vorsichtig sein als Deutscher mit
nazivergleichen aber das was da passiert
auch vor allem wie er handelt dass er
das Land versucht zu zerstören die
Ukraine wie er die Massen mobilisiert
das ist doch Hitler eins zu eins in
Kopie oder
es gibt Parallelen zum Faschismus bei
Mussolini auf die haben auch schon
einige Autoren vor gut zehn Jahren
hingewiesen man sieht meines Erachtens
seit 2012 dass die das Regime immer mehr
radikalisiert und immer mehr zum Opfer
und zur Geisel seiner eigenen Rhetorik
wird es wird mittlerweile nicht mehr um
sag mal begrenzte Ziele es geht nicht
mehr um NATO um Sicherheit um sozusagen
gemeinsamer oder teilbare Güter sondern
es geht um ein fundamentalkonflikt einen
Wertekonflikt mit dem Westen Putin sieht
sich als geschichtsvollstrecker er redet
ähnlich wie Hitler von einem
Tausendjährigen Reich ja dass da
irgendwie wieder hergestellt werden
müsste insofern ist da kaum mehr was
verhandelbar gleichzeitig aber auch die
Rhetorik wie 38 bei Hitler ja gebt mir
dann bin ich saturiert also gibt mir die
tschechowakei damals und jetzt aber die
Ankündigung gebt mir doch diese vier
Gebiete und auf der Basis hätten wir
dann Frieden schließen also weiterhin
das Spiel mit der Kriegsangst des
Westens und der Appell sozusagen dann
Appeasement Beschwichtigung zu machen
auch da gibt es taktische Parallelen zu
dem was Hitler gemacht hat jetzt muss
man bei Ihnen dazu sagen und wissen dass
sie ja schon
2014/2015 über die Radikalisierung des
putinismus geschrieben haben also schon
vor acht Jahren diese Entwicklung im
präzise analysiert und vorhergesehen
haben wie soll der Westen jetzt auf die
Entwicklung reagieren ich meine wir
haben ja gerade die Reaktion der NATO
gehört von Stoltenberg und anderen ist
das in dieser Situation angemessen oder
müsste der Westen jetzt nicht noch viel
deutlicher reagieren
also die entscheidende Frage hat ja
durchaus selensky aufgeworfen können wir
mit Putin noch Frieden schließen oder
muss das Ziel des Westens wie bei
silensky erklärtermaßen jetzt auch sein
wir können eigentlich nur einen stabilen
Frieden im Ergebnis dieses Krieges haben
nach Putin das heißt de facto muss man
sich entscheiden wollen wir darauf
hinwirken dass Putin so geschwächt aus
dem Krieg herausgeht dass er entweder
alles unterschreibt um zu Hause zu
überleben oder es einen Nachfolger gibt
weil er seine Kriegsziele nicht
erreichen kann davor drückt sich der
Westen vor dieser Entscheidung nach wie
vor und meines Erachtens muss man die
totale Ansage die Putin macht ernst
nehmen und sagen wir müssen auch Komplex
an das ganz ganzheitlich Herangehen an
dieses Kriegsgeschehen und uns fragen wo
sind die Schwachpunkte und die
Schwachpunkte müssen systematisch nicht
nur militärisch ausgenutzt werden dazu
gehört die Bevölkerung dazu gehört
mögliche Kriegsdienstverweigerung die
Session dazu Oligarchen dazu gehören
auch Widersprüche bei den russischen
Militärs dazu gehört China Indien
globaler Süden alle Schwachpunkte zu
China kommen gleich noch mal wir wollen
jetzt noch mal schauen auf Berliner
Reaktionen und zwar hat sich gestern
Abend in der ARD aus Ministerin baerbock
zur Lage geäußert
dieses annektionstheater und die
scheinreferenten die jetzt aufgeführt
wurden sind in Moskau das sind
eigentlich nur die halbherzigen versuche
über das hinwegzutäuschen was wir seit
einem halben Jahr erleben ein Landraub
mit brutalstar Gewalt mit Methoden die
man sich überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen
kann dass das Menschen anderen Menschen
antun können und deswegen ist vollkommen
klar dass dieser brutale Bruch der
un-kater von eigentlich keinem Land auf
dieser Welt akzeptiert werden kann und
der Goa in Generalsekretär der Vereinten
Nationen hat heute ja auch noch mal
deutlich gemacht dass das nicht
akzeptabel ist und ich kann mir kaum
vorstellen dass viele Länder das
überhaupt anerkennen werden wir haben
bei der Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen ja schon letzte Woche gesehen
dass auch die Länder die zu Beginn
dieses Krieges gesagt haben das ist eine
europäische Angelegenheit dass sie
aufgrund der Auswirkungen die sie spüren
auch selber dass sie aufgrund dessen wie
die un-karte verachtet wird
nicht machen auch sie stehen nicht an
der Seite Russlands wir akzeptieren
diese Art der Gewalt nicht wir
akzeptieren diese Methode nicht dass
Menschen mit vorgehaltener Waffe dazu
gezwungen werden ihr Land aufzugeben und
ja wir nehmen die Worte des russischen
Präsidenten seit dem ersten Tag dieses
Krieges ernst aber wir lassen uns vom
russischen Präsidenten nicht erpressen
weil auch deutlich geworden ist dass es
ihm um keinen Millimeter darum geht
irgendwie zu verhandeln sondern dass es
ihm darum geht das gesamte Land die
Ukraine einzunehmen und der ja auch
immer wieder deutlich gemacht hat dass
er auch nicht davor zurückschrecken
würde andere Länder anzugreifen und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir
international geschlossen die Ukraine
bei ihrem Recht auf Selbstverteidigung
verteidigen Ukraine hatte ja bereits vor
diesem brutalen Angriffskrieg diesen
Wunsch geäußert und wir haben mit
Ausbruch dieses Krieges mit dem Angriff
Russlands auf die Ukraine deutlich
gemacht dass wir die Ukraine bei ihrem
Recht auf Selbstverteidigung
unterstützen wir haben jeden Tag in
voller Verantwortung reflektiert wie wir
die Ukraine weiter unterstützen können
damit Menschenleben gerettet werden
können aber wir haben auch vom ersten
Tag an deutlich gemacht dass wir eine
Verantwortung dafür tragen dass der
Krieg sich nicht auf andere Länder
ausweitet dass die NATO nicht selbst
Kriegspartei wird und das gilt auch
heute auch über 200 Tage nach diesem
brutalen Angriff auf die Ukraine wir
unterstützen die Ukraine weiterhin auch
mit schweren Waffen bei ihrem Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung aber wir tun alles
dafür dass nicht andere Länder dass die
NATO in diesen Krieg nicht hineingezogen
wird
Außenministerin Berber gestern in der
ARD wir schauen nach New York eine
Resolution im UN-Sicherheitsrat mit der
die internationale Gemeinschaft
aufgerufen worden wäre die Annexion
nicht anzuerkennen wurde von Russland
gestern Abend mit einem Veto verhindert
China enthielt sich
Vereinigten Staaten haben zusammen mit
Albanien eine Resolution eingebracht um
die illegalen sogenannten Referenden auf
ukrainischem Gebiet zu verurteilen die
Resolution ist ganz klar sie verurteilt
diese illegalen Referenden und fordert
alle Staaten auf
diese Ergebnisse nicht anzuerkennen und
fordert Russland auf seine Truppen
unverzüglich aus der Ukraine abzuziehen
von Zielen von ihnen haben wir in den
letzten Tagen gehört dass sie meinen das
ganze ginge zu schnell vonstatten aber
eins mache ich ganz klar was
zu schnell vonstatten ging war das
russische handeln
und als Rat mussten wir reagieren und
dafür gibt es ja den Sicherheitsrat wir
sind gezwungen festzustellen dass einige
unserer Kollegen im rate wirklich hier
tief gesunken sind auch die letzten
Reste der würde wurden mit Füßen
getreten also ich kenne kein anderes
Beispiel wo ein Sicherheitsrat
resolution verabschie betteln die direkt
einen Mitglied des Sicherheitsrates
verurteilt hätten erwarten Sie wirklich
ernsthafte das Russland diese
Entschließung unterstützt und wenn nicht
bedeutet dass dass sie uns
bewusste drängen unser
Vetorecht auszuüben um dann nach draußen
zu sagen wir müssen brauchen unser Vito
dieses Handeln der Schwestern zeigt dass
man nicht bereit ist sich eben
Sicherheitsrates zu engagieren das ist
eine Erfahrung die wir schon in Jahren
gemacht haben und alle sind tief
gesunken das ist ganz klar die
Referenden wurden durchgeführt gemäß dem
Völkerrecht selbst wenn unsere
westlichen Gegner oder sogar der
Generalsekretär das Gegenteil
beweisen wollen der Generalsekretär
hatte nicht dass man darf aber er sagt
er bespreche im Namen der Vereinten
Nation aber es geht mehr als 100
internationale Wahlbeobachter aus
Italien
und die haben anerkannt dass das eine
legitime
Volksabstimmung war heute wurde eine
marionettenshow organisiert um das auf
der Hand liegende zu leugnen das
aggressive Abenteuer Regime in Russland
ist auf dem Wege zu seiner
bevorstehenden Niederlage ich werde dich
angehen auf Lügen die überhaupt nichts
mit der Realität zu tun haben denn die
Realität sieht ganz anders aus in der
Realität hat Putin versucht sich Land
anzueignen
im Gebieten wo er noch nicht mal vor Ort
die Kontrolle hat die Realität ist das
ukrainische Kräfte auch weiterhin ihre
Oper Fortsetzung um unsere souveränen
Gebiete zu betreiben und in die Realität
wurden mindestens 30 Zivilisten getötet
und 88 verletzt also die westliche Welt
kritisiert massiv das was Russland da
gestern gemacht hat und die
weitergehenden Angriffe Russland legt
einfach das Veto ein aber China enthält
sich wie ist es zu bewerten
also china hat ja auch zusammen mit
Indien schon bei der ersten Resolution
nach dem 24.2 also im Kriegsbeginn
Russland nicht unterstützt und dass sie
in die entscheidende Botschaft also
russland hat eigentlich keinen
Bündnispartner mehr das Gerät auch unter
Druck von China das am Anfang Russland
unterstützt hat weil das dachte eine
Woche aber mittlerweile zahlt China den
Preis dafür und China ist nicht mehr
bereit Putin zu retten insofern ist der
zeitliche Druck auf Putin sozusagen
diesen Krieg zu beenden von seinen
verbliebenen Bündnispartnern hoch er ist
in den Vereinten Nationen nicht nur im
Sicherheitsrat isoliert es wird in Folge
dieses vetus eine Abstimmung in der
Generalversammlung geben wo es noch mal
eine Verurteilung gibt das heißt der
versucht die Staaten des globalen Südens
auf die Seite Russlands zu ziehen ist
gescheitert schauen wir noch auf die
Situation in Deutschland Schrägstrich in
der Europäischen Union mit Blick auf die
Energiefrage Putin hat ja gestern
einigermaßen zynisch gesagt so dass so
ungefähr lasst sie registrieren da in
der Europäischen Union was bedeutet das
für uns was kommt da vor dem Hintergrund
dass man sich überlegt was an den
Pipelines passiert ist was kommt da
möglicherweise ein hybrider
Kriegsführung auf Deutschland und die
Europäische Union in den nächsten Wochen
und Monaten zu die Hybride Kriegsführung
findet die ganze Zeit schon statt und
zeitweilig sind natürlich die Putin
Unterstützer hier innenpolitisch ins
Hintertreffen geraten aber wir kommen
jetzt in den Herbst wir kommen in den
Winter und die politische Unterstützung
die insgesamt noch stark ist für den
Kurs der Bundesregierung kann infolge
der gestiegenen Gaspreise und der Folgen
für den Mittelstand natürlich auch
einbrechen oder für die anderen die ihre
Rechnungen nicht mehr bezahlen können
und darauf spekuliert Putin wie viel
politisches Kapital haben die
europäischen Länder um diesen
sanktionskurs zu unterstützen gehen Sie
das davon aus dass Putin mögliche Unruhe
oder gar Unruhen führt
jede uni-ruhe ist ihm lieb und natürlich
erst mal ein Teilerfolg jetzt der der
Sieg einer einer quasi faschistischen
Regierung in Italien wo wir nicht wissen
ob danach sozusagen
die Sanktionen verlängert werden weil
die basieren auf dem Konsens Prinzip
obwohl Frau Meloni schon sehr deutlich
sich geäußert hat und die Entwicklung
kritisiert hat also rund um die
Annektion das hat sie aber Putin hat
natürlich auch Sardinien Vergangenheit
und konnte unterstützt in Italien das
heißt es gibt durchaus in Italien einen
nennenswertes pro putin-lager wenn die
sich verbinden mit wenn man den Stimmen
die es in Ungarn gibt oder auch in
Bulgarien dann weiß ich nicht wie lange
die sanktionsrohr hält Professor
heinemann-grüder war das bei uns im
Studio ich sage vielen Dank für Ihre
Zeit und danke für diese ausführlichen
analy